americans spend around 365 billion a
year for prescription drugs and the
prices here are higher than in many
other countries but mark cuban
billionaire investor says
he's got a way to help with a new online
pharmacy called costplusdrugs.com
and the company says it can offer lower
prices for more than 800 generic drugs
mark who is also owner of the nba's
dallas mavericks is here to talk about
it mark thank you for being here thanks
for having me welcome uh you know other
billionaires do other things with their
time and money and their money
why did you want to do this and then how
are you able to do this well first i
mean the why is very simple i mean we
all know people who have had to make
decisions between their rent and food
and medication or they've had to ration
their medication and that's just wrong
in the united states of america in 2022
and so the why was really easy and the
how i literally had a doctor dr alex
oshmayansky who cold emailed me and he
was building a pharmacy that uh that was
able to make
rare drugs more cost effectively and i
was like why eliminate the rare drugs
let's build a company and rather than
working within the traditional system
let's work outside of it and just
have complete transparency and seller
drugs at a set marked up of cost plus 15
percent so that's what we do if you go
to costplusdrugs.com put in the
medication that you take and you'll see
one what we pay for it from
manufacturers you'll see our markup of
15 percent yeah we charge a three dollar
handling fee and then we charge five
dollars for shipping that's it and when
you add that at all so simple it almost
sounds too good to be true
remember what your mom said yeah
yeah yeah what's happened is the legacy
drug industry they it's worked for them
right so why change it yeah and
typically when someone starts a company
to try to disrupt drug pricing they try
to work within the existing system
because that's where the money is
and so you know i'm blessed financially
so i was able to work with doc with alex
and say look let's go after generics
first let's be completely transparent so
people can trust us
and let's sell drugs and it's just blown
up it's insane the way we've changed
people and it's shaking up the industry
for sure all the while you said you
don't spend money on marketing this is
word of mouth people that are actually
saying this is helping my life without
question and unfortunately there's more
people who are looking to save money
anywhere in their life because so much
else in their life is going up in price
without question so without question i
mean do you think at this point we're
headed for a recession and more trouble
you know what i can only control what i
can control right our mission at cost
plus drugs is to be the low-cost
provider for every medication on the
planet yeah right and so right now we're
at 800 plus generics but we'll be adding
brand random medications as well so
we're talking to all the biggest
companies and our biggest challenge is
just getting them to sell to us but once
we get there we really think we can
disrupt and turn the whole
pharmaceutical industry upside but so
this guy just sends you a cold email you
don't know him did you ever believe it
when you read it did you think i want to
get into this or did you you did i mean
because why not follow up right so
shark tank instinct kicking in you know
100 right yeah 100 but you know
dr ashmayansky is a radiologist he has a
phd in mathematics he does scientific
research and just for fun he went to law
school for a year you know he's kind of
a smart guy and so that that came
through very quickly and he did the work
right and that's the key so you know he
does he's the ceo and runs the minute by
minute day by day and i deal with
strategic and marketing and and finances
and you know we're we're growing so
quickly we're already past our two-year
expectations and we've only been
shipping for five months
you you have so fascinated by you mark
cuban yeah yeah we all honestly you know
a lot of people admire you because you
have found success you are wealthy um
but the question i have when did you
feel like you needed to make more of an
impact on the world that you live in
because like tony opened up with
multi-millionaires billionaires they
spend their time spending their money
doing things that are very self-serving
right why do you feel like you want to
serve look i'm the luckiest guy in the
world you know and to to be able to find
something that can change people's lives
for the better why wouldn't i my next
dollar is not going to change my life
one way or the other you know it's not
going to make a difference for my
children or their children or their
children but if you know when you meet
people or having experienced it myself
when i didn't have any money like you
look at my fingers and you can see i
couldn't afford a doctor right i can
tell you other stories um but to be able
to create medication be able to make
medicine affordable that's a game
changer do you ever think about politics
mark only because you you've talked
about the biden administration that you
said has absolutely zero charisma you
you've said that
you're you're somebody that nobody can
question the charisma you have and i
know it takes more than charisma but do
you ever think about politics i mean
like everybody in this country right now
you think about it and you wonder you
know could i do a better job or any
number of a thousand people do a better
job but the underlying problem isn't
whether it's me it's really the duopoly
that we have yeah right the fact do we
really think that the republican and
democratic parties present the best
candidates and the answer is no right
and are there better both sides on both
sides right and so i'm a big fan of
ranked choice voting because i think it
opens up the candidate pool
significantly i love ranked choice yeah
i mean if
you know we can go talk for days about
that kind of stuff but i think you know
all the things that we talk about
whether it's abortion whether it's gun
control that's just about power dynamics
and i think to change those power
dynamics you have to work outside the
system and that's why cost plus drugs
see how i got it right back yeah yeah
that's our cost plus drudge.com we'll
save it for you cost plus drugs before
we go in one word cryptocurrency um i'm
still bullish bullish mark cuban we'll
be right back thank you very much